alright thank you very much for joining
us geg oslo for our second GDG app
clinic my name is reto Meier I'm a
developer advocate on the Android team
and joining me live from New York is a
Roman Nurik and in knee Luis Wellman yes
did I mention the we're in New York
rather than still alive very nice so
we're going to take a look at a few apps
from the excellent developers in Oslo
and we've got your work cut out for you
the guys from Prague we looked at last
time pretty impressive so I have to see
how well you do further north all right
so without further ado I'd like to
invite the developer of NSB to come up
and tell us a little bit about their app
and and about themselves and we can go
from that hello hello welcome to the
show thank you moving from your way so I
thought your app and introduce yourself
of course please yeah my name is John
I'm from NSB I'm a digital consultant
and I'm gonna talk about the NSB app
which we submitted it's the it's the 50
versions which so it's not released yet
the current version is 404 actually does
exist and so the new version has flat
design and so on and the meaning with
the app is for the new Asian train and
we can train company called nsp to
increase ticket availability get
real-time travel updates at the ability
to get a ticket on the phone so this is
n SP so this is the
you front page and as you can see it's
its shares a lot of the same somatic
elements as the previous version but
we've kind of lost that dashboard
pattern with the big giant oversized
buttons which I was one of the bits of
feedback that I had beforehand so
already this is looking a lot nicer
design here is really good it's really
clean there's a lot of things to like
about it um the main thing that that
bothered me when we first loaded it up
is as so many things are blank so for
instance if you press the button like a
train journey now you've used it a
little bit in the sense that you have a
couple of favorites i see they begin
with a just like my favorite skip but
when before before you have anything in
the favorites right or the journey or
before you've performed any surge that
area below the search bar is simply
playing however if you click in the
search bar which you might want to do
right now i don't know actually what's
gonna happen so that brings up the list
of matching stations and if it's you
know if you don't have anything in the
search bar you're all there so I my
first piece of advice is that should
always appear it's just logical there's
no reason that you just suddenly appear
when you click in the search bar versus
not being there okay the favorites are
more or less the same way when you don't
have any favorites it's literally just a
blank screen and the user has no way to
interact with it which is disturbing so
my suggestion would be that you actually
have something at the top of the screen
that you know for instance and add
favorites item I'm a big fan I don't
know how you feel about Roman but I'm a
big fan of Lists whose last item is add
another
yeah it's kind of following the
principle of direct manipulation the
thing that you're working on I mean the
actions that you can take on the thing
you're working on I directly on top of
what your what your so if you it's
kind of like if you remove an item from
a list simply swipe it away if you add
an item to the list it's at the bottom
of the list where that item it appeared
he would add know if you are planning I
think the I think this is really where
it shines yeah you uh you said I I thing
I yes of an era which is all your nurse
yeah generator okay using it on there so
I now you search search for couple
stations you plan a journey from them
and with one exception I think it's a
wonderful you I unfortunately with
Rachel server error the one exception
keeps popping up over and over which is
the your ticket is valid from spinner
pops to making a spinner that's flat one
thing we've noticed though is that even
though you know spinner back in two
thousand six was just really trendy it
hasn't ate well it it's not actually as
convenient to you I as you think it
might be and you notice that we've moved
off the spinner in some of our apps
towards more direct things like numeric
keypads it seemed to work a lot better
and sometimes for calendars especially
here it is free right so you can
actually use 30-day month calendars but
you know you flip up and down between
two different months it's a little more
square so it works better in the
fastback reaches its scrollable so
definite
where it's the longer content for longer
of spaces but it's just it's really easy
to wrap your head around so you can
actually visually see that the days of
the week which I think days in the week
or one of the most important aspects of
choosing their date especially when
you're planning a trip the probably
planning a trip around a weekend or
around specific data that going out or
whatever and visually seeing the place
in the week that you're choosing
something will give you that extra bit
of content so I definitely recommend
something like a month calendar I think
that you've started using a month but
kind of a 30 day view from RAF yeah when
I see something like this my first
thought is oh I guess I guess your
project manager has an iphone thankfully
I do yeah it's unfortunately I can't
quite get to the to the last bit where
we actually see the ticket but I think
one of the things which I noticed in
there in the previous version and I seen
a little bit of it here as well is that
every time you do something which
requires contact with the server we get
a little flash up dialogue telling us
that we are communicating something with
the server you know that's something
which which I really think takes away
from the magic of our mobile phones work
I mean we all know that it's connected
to the Internet and needs to talk to
your server and do all that stuff you're
kind of what you use to think that it's
just a magic thing where your phone just
knows how to train things the fact that
there's an internet connection in mobile
telephony all of that is just kind of
completely hidden away so you want to
try and make sure that you're not
displaying any of those sorts of
dialogues particularly because usually
they just come up really quickly you
know you have you know you just have a
sort of a flash of talking to server and
if it all works it flashes away you just
kind of think as a user what was that
was that important should i have read
that so you really want to try and just
disguise all of that unless something
goes wrong and if it does go wrong try
and be as descriptive as you can in a
way that
doesn't rely on understanding how your
app is being implemented to your user so
something like unable to buy train
tickets no connection to internet found
something like that is more useful than
you know server communication error
where the user is like I don't know what
any of that means did I do something
wrong rather than okay well I can try
again later because you know my
connectivity is down there may be more
easily able to understand okay so we
just got the schedule which you may be
able to see here if I can hold it still
enough I realize that's not having three
very well you can see that's a really
clean design it's got the nice red band
at the top everything else is monochrome
but there's a fairly good
differentiation using using fonts and
highlighting I think you know based on
the specific application and I'm not
familiar with trains of Norway at all
but I can readily believe that they are
all color coded in different shades of
grey but if they're not and if there is
another film coating that might be a
really nice additional effect is to add
some more information that's going to
help people find the platform or the
particular train that they're looking
for um but this does a good job of not
being too busy I think my honor if I
were to redesign as I might just use our
in font on the city names yeah that's
like I mean that's one of the best ways
to add a touch of elegance to your apps
as well as help even further tweet the
hierarchy the visual hierarchy to get
context it's used different ways of
Roboto different sizes not too many
sizes most needed to really at most
three bears landed but different font
weight living help Indian market but
yeah I like you're sending into the
higher fuse is very evident as if I
think women would probably say that you
know
according the entire time in the same
way is wrong worse the hours old did it
this kid yeah this looks really good and
I especially I don't know if you can see
it but I love the way that the platform
is in a little box hmm really easy to
see and it also is a little nervous kind
of elegant so that's very nice yeah I
have to say you know the biggest
feedback i have i have a page of notes
which i've tried to take on each of the
apps and they were all based on version
4 and version 5 fixes all of them social
life my feedback is a nice job on the on
virtual 5 you've really updated the app
brought it into sort of the modern age
of Android wear its action bar holo
theme nice clean flat lines a lack of
clutter simple intuitive navigation so a
lot of the little niggles that i had
around making it sort of more of a
modern up today that i think you could
give absolutely nailed so yeah nicely
done the one the one thing i wanted to
mention is about the home screen we
spend a little time talking about
onboarding flows and i think that you
know outside of the Google Play listing
the very first thing you see in the app
is probably your most important inch
screen it's almost one hero limit so i
would spend even more time on this on
this landing screen to a tweak it a bit
right now it feels very static that's
one of the problems that we moved away
but one of the reasons we moved away
from the dashboard pattern and and
anything that basically just has links
on it we moved more towards a content
driven home screen so one of the things
we may wanna consider doing is things
like profile you may want to move into
like the action bar since it is
navigation but it's often treated as an
action it's kind of like a common thing
to put the profile in looking over flood
or something and then things like you
ticket if you don't have a ticket the
reason to I get show that I'm guessing
but you can also just you know have it
as a I don't want to say card but have
it as a scrollable item you can get to
feel another thing
another thing to think about is this
would be a perfect opportunity you use
some of the new action detection hi
because if if you know that a person is
in the middle of a training journey then
probably the first thing they want to do
is you would take that's probably why
they pulled it out of their pocket begin
with because construction conductor is
coming down the aisle I that would be a
truly mad at the moment to all you see
exactly what you need and then perhaps
heights on this other step either on the
action bar or in a drawer or some other
way somewhere out of there well
understood way to access these
navigational points yeah so like it's
almost like Google now it tries to
predict what your what you may be most
interested in here you may be able to
say if you are if you're if you think
that the user is in a place where they
want to access that ticket show that
ticket opps actually show the actual
ticket at the very top and then show
other options like favorites and then
let's say like me even potentially place
the entire search screen or the
beginning of the search process into the
screen so you basically kind of give
easy access and media access the very
first step of each of those flows and
then once the user decides that hey yeah
i do want to view the full ticket they
just touch that tile and they get to the
full ticket here but in the position is
based on things like activity defection
another thing that i think would be
incredibly useful here but significantly
more work would be integration with a
map view that's one of the things I
noticed when I'm I i frequently need
transit in a city that I'm unfamiliar
with the first thing I'll view is open
my mouth figure out where I need to go
try to find a station nearby and then
get directions to that I so that's one
thing that thing could be really nice if
you feel that you're on many of your
users might be going up when your
location of course if they're going to
familiar locations it's great to just
happen those favorites again and
in fact that's probably one of the bits
a feedback I have based on sort of what
Ian and Roman have just been talking
about is that right now your your home
screen kind of looks as though was
designed based on your API endpoints so
we have an API which lets us you know
call for the train journey we have
another one which lets us retrieve our
favorites one which gives us access to
our profile those sort of data driven
design it would be really interesting to
see a reimagine vision of the home
screen based around the guidelines that
Roman and in we're talking about which
is what does it user want to do when
they open up the app what are they
thinking what are the most likely things
for someone who uses this everyday or
someone who is in it was visiting Oslo
how are they going to take advantage of
the app and try and think about
redesigning the UI from the perspective
of what you want to do rather than
what's available for you to do so I you
know I definitely agree I think putting
things like the ticket on the you know
the bottom of the main screen seems like
an obvious thing to me if I have a
ticket already and it's valid you know
have it there and if I don't it seems
like the most likely thing I'm going to
want to do with the app is buy a ticket
so having a big plus symbol there so
that you can you know initiate that that
that action right from the beginning
seems like it might be useful so yeah
that's i would consider redesigning the
home screen which is really the only
thing which hasn't changed much in the
redesigns to be more of a what is it
that you think people want to do and
reduce the number of steps for them to
be able to get to the specific action
that they have installed this app for
now before we move on I want to point
out the one feature that none of us have
talked about but which is really
incredibly well done and that's
localization yes I mean I we did not ask
for this app in English but there it is
showing us almost completely an English
except for I don't know what reader is
the name of the company well there you
go
I wondered the same yeah it's the
equivalent of Amtrak I guess yeah no
absolutely totally agree like this is
something which a lot of people overlook
when they're building apps for a
specific location as they figure well
you don't need to localize the train app
for for Norway right like it's going to
be used by a Norwegian people except
when it isn't which is what i found out
when i was traveling around italy trying
to buy tickets on train italia and their
website does not localize anything but
italian and that makes it an intriguing
challenge to a 2 pi URL tickets in a 400
italian come on well you know i prefer
not to um but yeah so that's that's this
sort of you know thinking as to who you
all your potential users are is really
really valuable because suddenly you
have everyone who's visiting he's going
to use this app because it's all
localized they feel comfortable it looks
familiar it works in a familiar way and
they understand what it says so yeah
thank you for for localizing it
certainly makes our job is to reviewers
easier and I think it's going to help to
grow your audience of potential users
online as well but which languages are
localized into y which languages do you
have translations or you're out it's I
think it's connected to the language in
the phone but i think it's not only in
the region in english okay you might
want to add chinese chinese okay noted
yeah it's an easy one yeah other side
you at caesars that's true yeah alright
perfect thank you John and thank you for
your patience in and letting us detour
around your app and come back into it do
you or anything else that you'd like to
add in terms of responding to our
feedback or things which you have a plan
to do but perhaps haven't had time to
influence in the current version
not really i'm going to take this the
notes back to the team and we'll discuss
it awesome yeah i'm looking forward to
seeing version 5 when it comes out for
real so it's definitely a great job a
really good update so nicely done yeah
thank you thank you very much hi I'm
Alex I'm the creator of phone locator
else this project started in 2007 on
symbian when an Android was just in its
infancy so the idea back then was to
track my own motorcycle tour around
Europe I wanted to show my friends back
home where I was and where my friend was
as well so I may I made the appt it had
no login there nothing you just joke
there was just a website you could just
see where this 11 nokia phone was in
those days gps on phones was completely
new so quite late actually last year i
released this android version which
represents about 120 hours of work it
has all the same features in that the
Symbian 11 did which it kind of morphed
into a security product long before it
was built into your iPhone or Android
device so you can you can send this from
a text message containing the word along
doing my friends going to try that now
and it will it will sound an alarm so
you can find the phone
so just so it creates a notification you
have to deactivate the notification you
can choose whether or not you want to
hide that message so that the person who
has the phone could see it or not you
can set a passcode as well so that the
person who has the phone has to type in
a passcode before they can disable the
alarm it has a buddy message feature so
if the sim card in the phone is changed
it will text the predefined number
saying this is the new number that's in
the in the telephone and of course it
periodically updates its location so you
can see the time of that it's going to
update in in 10 minutes it's pretty it
is you have to be pretty conservative
with with the updates it was before this
new google play services low low power
stuff I'd Dakota or myself to try and
decide whether it's going to use GPS or
Wi-Fi to work out with a furnace here so
it here the symbian version had four
hundred thousand registered users the
Android version is you know a fraction
of that only a few thousand people have
used it I think so yeah that's for okay
okay okay nice so thank you for the
update so so I had a few thoughts you
know based on my first experience of
using and I think probably the biggest
feedback I have is that it's not
immediately obvious when you install it
what it does or how to use it so without
getting sort of your your two-minute
intro there it's it's not entirely clear
like you have to create a login and then
it take a taste of GPS and sends it to a
server but it's not immediately obvious
when i'm using the app what it's doing
with any of that or it rocks yeah
exactly so it's not a sort of starts to
get you a little bit nervous you know it
also the amount of time it takes to sort
of get set up
is kind of longer than you'd expect like
you have to go to the website to create
this whole profile and username by me I
knew you or taper okay so so let me tell
you let me tell you what it's not really
an excuse but this is there's some
legacy that this this app was made
before it was actually standard to use
HTTP and Jason to through actually
update so it uses a really low bandwidth
protocol to send the the updates to the
server binary protocol and in in those
days making forms and things on symbian
was hard work so for all why not just do
it on the web and then I when I came to
do the Android version i nearly changed
it so you like a proper login screen and
everything but during the end I thought
or we'll just I just I just use the same
web interface so rather than recoding it
but I take the point it's a it's not
very intuitive well see now you've got
an advantage you could actually take
advantage of the fact that you've
procrastinated this long and just use
Google+ sign-in instead so then you know
how to do the form or anything clanked
etiquette so it gets simple so you get
rewarded for having put it off but there
are you a neat way to sort of reduce the
friction of that initial sign-in flow I
would like to say one thing about that
so there's two things that are really
important about the beginning of your
out here first is that you can be
something without having to pop it it's
something that's difficult to do but in
this case for instance there are some
here's that you can enable without
logging in that might you know give the
user some idea of what they're getting
into you but the other thing is to make
the law how could how could that work
well for instance I in this case you can
set your buddy message I I think there's
like a couple other things you can you
know some settings and things like that
no obviously the app has no
functionality
on right for instance the screw we're
looking at now could give some message
like you know you would have a next
update in two minutes if you were logged
in which you're not and then are they a
facility for logging un sure the other
thing that you want to think about
though is how many clicks it takes to
login on the website forms it's a lot
and complete completely agrees is afraid
of this common this God got to change
its that this actor is actually going to
be retired and replaced with some new
brand there's something completely
awesome you want to potentially a
similar thing you could do and this is
all part of kind of that onboarding flow
which is so important especially if you
ever get featured you know a lot of
people get into your app that don't know
about your brand don't know what it does
one things you could do is say here's
your current location like let's say
we're in New York and then maybe even
show preview over the websites kind of
crazy but you can show a preview of the
website showing the map with your
location saying here's what you would
see if you're on a computer and you have
the service you would see that your
phone is in New York so you can almost
use the live data see where the person
is because you don't need to log in to
get their location and then just kind of
show a fake version of the website show
in that location that might be you know
some way of hitting the value using this
direct kind of in a direct way rather
than just talking about remember the
rental make it easy to download and it's
a lot about so one usage pattern we see
a lot as if people will search for a
term install 5 or 10 apps that seem to
have Association for that firm and then
they will uninstall the ones they don't
like after about 20 seconds apiece so
first of 20 of 30 seconds that's crucial
if I had even said five seconds is
crucial
yeah okay so you've got your vinegar
it's like a web page you've got a few
seconds to impress and then that's that
you're you blown it exactly yeah cool
just on that on that point it's not even
after you install the app before you
even install the app right so the
screenshots the app icon and we will
play the description all of that is part
of that user experience that initial
onboarding experience the very first
time the user and it has any sort of
communication with your brand or any
sort of interaction with you as do that
so that that is even before you gets the
app is very current way of putting it
thank you so I've got a new brand that's
it's made by designer not by me i'm a
developer and it's a it looks really
cool awesome but by the way this app is
open source so anybody who's watching
and feels wants to get involved and that
would be brilliant if they say they
could find me it's not github hey
something so a couple of other points
along the same lines i think i think
probably the biggest feedback is you
know based on where the app has come
from right so it's an app that you've
been around for a long time based
originally and see me and think we all
know that the world has changed
significantly in terms of the way mobile
phone apps look and work you know since
that time even though it's surprisingly
short period of time has passed a lot
has changed so you know i think a lot of
the feedback is going to be along those
lines you know i'd love to see you
integrate the new location based
services as well to try and help make
that the location updates a little bit
more efficient and Google+ sign-in as
well as an alternative to potentially to
having to create a new account each time
and I also notice that we are forced
into portrait mode that doesn't work
tablet which makes a lot of sense in
some instances but it might be
interesting to see how an app like this
would work on a tablet if there is some
functionality that you could continue to
use you know things like GPS updates
would even if there's security aspects
of being able to call the phone aren't
available men also want to give just a
little bit more thought to your action
bar layout it doesn't seem like the
ordering of the menu is is effective in
terms of getting the most important
things on the action bar there's some
things that probably shouldn't ever
leave the overflow menu for instance
settings is almost never necessary as an
action bar action actual our button I
also noticed that if you go to you know
for instance buddy message settings can
you do that retail on your phone no not
settings with buddy message settings
which is also you know that's something
that might want to live under settings
rather than under a different menu item
um this I this page I think would be
really a good candidate for the gun
cancel action bar pattern hmm absolutely
okay yeah and you want it one of the
good things about this after that it's
simple like it's it doesn't have a
cluttered you why you don't have a
million different things confronting you
on screen but you've kind of almost gone
sort of to fire in that direction and
that it's a lot of the stuff we could
quite easily have put on the main screen
because all we have there is a countdown
so you can certainly add a few more
elements to that to explain what happens
when that countdown runs out and you
know basically like this buddy message
for example you could have that
displayed on screen I'm going to have
the if you don't if you don't set the
body message it does warn you that
you've not set the body message it does
on the main screen but it doesn't tell
me what that means it just says you
haven't set a buddy
search and it's like okay is that a bad
thing go fact I don't even know what a
bloody message is precisely i'm still
not sure with a buddy messages yes this
is what we we get there you haven't set
a body message and you have the button
to fix it which is good that it's an
actionable prompt to be able to go in
there and fix but again you have no idea
of what the implications are and as a
user the first time I open up the app
this is what I see and so I'm basically
being told hey you're doing something
wrong you haven't done this thing yet so
you know I don't even know if you
deserve to use my app which isn't really
the kind of feeling you want to give
people right you want to make them feel
happy feel like they're doing the right
thing and that if there's something
which isn't set it's you know I'm sure
you just haven't gotten around to it or
you know here's a thing which we could
use to make your app make this happy
even more useful to you so you want to
provide a little bit of context you want
to try and be more positive in terms of
the messaging in terms of just what this
will allow you to do rather than how you
haven't done this thing okay cool yes I
think that's about all of the feedback
that I had enough there's any more
specific stuff it's it's the thing is
it's not it's not particularly complex
which means that you know once you get
kind of past those those initial sorts
of bits of feedback there's not too much
else that we can provide a dis stage but
hopefully that's useful for him so do
you think I see us thanks very much guys
really appreciate that yeah oh yeah
thank you guys all right hello can you
hear me absolutely fantastic okay first
off just thank you very much for doing
this we really appreciate you taking the
time and yeah so def in app where to
start i can tell you a little bit about
your company it's a reasonably
recognized the company in norway in
terms of a lot of people know who thin
are and we have about the website have
about three and a half million visitors
a week unique visitors and they're like
5 million people in norway and it's a
marketplace for
properties bits and pieces cars its
place where you go to find jobs etc so
the so what we've done is we're actually
in the process of making this Android
app and it's an alpha at the moment and
it's a few months away from launch and
it's the first time we actually showing
it off to anyone outside Finn so that's
pretty cool thank you yes and the idea
behind the app is to make it faster for
people to access the content of thin so
at the moment we have we have a sort of
like a web platform for mobile phones
and what happens is that if you go onto
Finn you have to go through a number of
steps in order to do a search so what a
lot of people do is they go on to Finn
and then dream about like you know
upgrading the house or wherever it is so
to spend a lot of time searching
searching through two things that are on
Finn and in our current web app for
mobile what you have to do is see you
open it up and then you click on a
market and then you click on a sub
market and then you have to select the
location and go through all the filters
and then you click search and then
you're at the results page so it's like
a pretty long process so what we wanted
to do with this app was try to squeeze
down the navigation path a little bit
and also do something that we haven't
done before and that is to try to be a
little bit smart about how we deliver
updates and relevant info to the user so
we have so the main page the landing
page that you see when you open app is
like a stream of content and the idea is
for that content to show new hits on
searches that you have going on
and updates to things that you were
looking for all right well yeah why
don't you tell us a little bit about
what we're missing while I get installed
over here well it's very pretty up the
now that the navigation departs pretty
significantly from what we consider the
current android standards um we
certainly can't say that it's bad it's
just it's non-standard so it has a
possibility of confusing the user and
maybe making making their learner
learning curve a little higher than it
has to be it doesn't use the standard
action bar for instance it uses a
non-standard for pattern detect if to
confuse me already because there seemed
to be multiple drawers that come out at
different times I but it is very
beautiful app it's it's sort of hard
bass um a little bit it's very very open
and easy on the eyes lots of open space
maybe a little too much but not much I
didn't like the margin particle you'll
see what we're talking about in just a
second here i'll go ahead and wait for
you great we can switch okay so now we
gotta know what's James Ray is because
I'm seeing some amazing houses I think
we've got buying today you don't want it
so it's very pricey in Norway well we
live in the Silicon Valley and I can
assure you it's not cheap yeah so we
have the right version on screen right
now it proves so it's a good example
right so what we saw before hand was
what happens if you just get a website
wrap it in a native rapper and stick it
on stick it up it doesn't look great
it's it's slow it's janky you know it's
really not an optimized situation so
what we have here is exactly what
happens when you do it the right way and
create something which is truly native
to give that
that richer experience so we can see
what you were talking about now with
that sort of stream of content right on
the landing page as soon as you go in
you know you've shown things so suddenly
you're not having to think about
navigating through different areas of
shopping but you shown actual content
that you can engage in and get some
thinking about what it is that you're
interested in that's an ask a question
I'm going through these cards that all
have the same heading which is good no I
may also many different yes I'll just
explain that very quickly and we have
the ID is for that stream that you see
on the homepage to have a Content that
relates to your searches so new results
on searches that you make but were we
haven't been able to implement that bit
yet we're sort of in a process of doing
it but this we have what we call curated
content as well which is the we call it
a fin cat we have a Muscat as we weird
but we have a mascot there is a cat and
its really sarcastic and it makes all
these sarcastic comments about different
things so he's that's the cap that's
sort of posting all this little updates
on to the stream so the idea is to have
like a mix mix of updates from that cat
but also like you know new new hits on
the searches are you making nice love to
get Jose from a sarcastic cat that
sounds that sounds like the coolest
feature so far that's such a great way
to make a go a true like form a true
emotional bond with your users to give
them like a personality that they're
working is almost like when they open
the app they're going to talking to the
cat yeah I particularly like the idea
that it's such as that it's a sarcastic
cat too it's not like a helpful friendly
cat makes all the records totally like
you know you in your face making fire do
I think that's excellent I hope not so I
think
the one thing that I'm seeing on the
home I am very comfortable with outside
but it does seem like it's going to take
me awhile to get anywhere and I wonder
if there's something I you know a few
techniques you used to for instance
compress some of the information you
know once I've seen the photos I I made
anything why I asked about the headers I
may be able to locate our that I'm
looking for afterwards just by looking
at the header so you could give them
something like slide parts over the top
of one another or you know shrink them
down or something you know once the user
has has seen them so that getting to the
bottom or navigating around doesn't take
as many swipes yeah you could use a
similar approach to what we have in
Google now and some of the cards are
sort of consists of other cards laying
on top of each other that you press to
expand or I'll move around that way be
quite interesting yam it's a very
attractive-looking appetit it's
interesting the way you've implemented
the sliding drawer for search so this is
basically where you have your categories
as well as the actual searching is that
right yeah that's right so that's all
the main markets and are more markets to
be added on to that okay and I assume
that what i'm reading on-screen here
means search fin yeah so that's a global
search for all the markets cool what do
you think about the idea of using a draw
Panthers for search categories room um
yeah I'm you look over all my might be
back here is at the the drawer like you
mentioned beginning the drawer enews in
different ways well as hierarchy within
the jar actually having a back button or
I guess up within the drawers is barely
we have folks to be somewhat confused
because you end up creating lots of
modes and states where like I could
actually see that I could get the jar to
it's like child screen right but he I
guess what you have now slide over the
content and then maybe you know a few
minutes later I slide over to expand and
I can
we forgot that the jar was in the state
of being or it was in the mode of kind
of the child view so there's a lot of
hierarchy in the drawer there's a lot of
different states for the drawer I really
try to simplify that the other thing is
that I mean we obviously do have
guidelines I want to talk too much about
guidelines here but we do navigation to
our guidelines he's dude apart quite a
bit from there so I've possible or try
to follow those and really I mean like
once you start searching once you start
going into the flow doing the search you
may want to just replace the main
content with each search filter that
done might simplify things mmm yeah I
think that's that's where you're
absolutely right thing that's where it
gets confusing is that once you're on
this screen here then search actually
mayor's refine search which is fine
except that it's different from what you
have in the home screen where search
means in a allow me to surge or let me
sort by category so it's kind of
different content even if it's related I
also found it a little bit I I always
find a little bit disconcerting when you
have sort of two sliding panels so we
have the sliding drawer on the left
search and we have the sliding drawer on
the right for for logging in yeah
particularly this log in peace feels
like it should be part of of an action
bar or something like that I think this
is very non discoverable and I assume
that pressing that is the same thing
right so you press the the profile
button and that drags it across but I
think you know this is the idea of the
way that we use you know there's the
sliding panels and the drawers as Roman
says this is very different from the way
we have on the design guidelines and so
it can be a little bit disconcerting
more counterintuitive to users who are
expecting it to work in it in a certain
way yeah it's sad though because it's
absolutely beautiful only have the
action here and the animation the colors
I it just it's really really nice
definitely um and I'd love to see some
of those elements prepped right just
yeah you have to think about what are
your users going to be experienced with
it's always tempting to go with an
entirely new design or to have you know
it's also very tempting sometimes to
just import design from another mobile
device family but you have to remember
that someone who's had their android
phone for a while who loves it will have
interacted with a lot of apps that offer
similar navigation and functionality to
yours perhaps in a different vertical
and this will be a learning experience
and learning experiences are sometimes
fun but they're often frustrating when
you have a task in mind that you want to
get done right I just want to mention
that we're actually struggling a little
bit to find a suitable pattern so we did
look through quite a few android apps
and android guidelines and looking for
something that sort of combined you know
drilling into your market and also
having the filter stir and part of
reason we did it like this was because
it sort of scaled up quite nicely when
you're on their tablet so you can have
the filter like constantly available on
the left-hand side so you can tweak the
filter as well see in real time updates
after off the results and a right hand
side and so works we thought like you
know this was something that kind of we
kind of know that it's not optimal but
we didn't we didn't find a better
solution to be honest yeah I he was
saying I think for the tablet layout it
would look great I think it's exactly
the sort of layout that you want to use
where you have everything on screen you
know here it almost feels is the I think
it's it's as well rather than any
individual problem it's more of a
combination of a lot of paradigms that
are being used slightly differently from
how you expect it
then as a as a experienced Android user
you start to get confused as to what you
need to do to navigate around it's
primarily around navigation so here for
example I'm sort of expecting to be able
to to swipe you know to bring something
back but I can't hear its its bag which
is an UP button which looks similar to
what i would expect an UP button to be
but looks different so it again gives me
that pause for thought like what is what
is this going to do so you're never
quite sure how to navigate back to where
you're from because here i need to
either hit back or I need to bring my
navigation drawer back and then hit back
in order to return to the previous menu
that's kind of unexpected I never expect
to have to slide out a drawer before I'm
able to navigate back up in the in the
hierarchy now I'm going to I'm going to
take a slightly contradictory positions
right down take this this app feels very
designed and it feels like every
interview that I have you know every
question I have about navigation is is
solved in an elegant manner I I do agree
that it's it's completely not standard
but I think we should recognize that a
lot of pradas got into this and there's
some interesting problems or what I
would really love to see with Romans up
for it is to have this be an Android
design in action candidate talk a little
bit about the challenges that you faced
how you solve them and see if we can
find something that fits into the
Android standard that solves them as
alligator now I think there's there's a
lot of there's a lot of hierarchy here
that's one of the hardest things you
look at the designers even with
different hierarchies and different
flows as well as obviously you know when
you mentioned before the tablet versus
one area how the things
kind of things respond to that in sizes
definitely no the next few episodes of
Angela's on an action we're looking to
kind of get back into the into the
redesign or the reimagining world so
definitely this is one of the absolute
authority yeah I think it's one of the
challenges that I've seen this a lot
from apps which are trying to do you
know some sort of shopping or anything
where you have to navigate through
multiple categories and then do multiple
sort of filtering you know on each of
those categories it becomes a real
challenge I've seen people try and do it
using drop downs in the action bar or
having you know the the filter controls
here on the top of the screen but then
that excuse all of the content so yeah
I've seen a lot of apps try and having
that sort of multi-level hierarchies
definitely a challenge so I would be
very interested to see what what Roman
and his team can come up with as blunt
alternatives one minor thing I wanted to
call out here so this this kind of
starts feeling a little bit like you
know this is solving the problem of
mastery geeks are right where do you
have you have master i guess when you
actually go to search you have the
search filter you almost have like it
takes a little bit of you know mental
gymnastics to see it but maybe it's kind
of like a master on the left and fell on
the right and what you end up happily in
the private achill e you're now in the
like the cars or music or the guitars or
things notice actually yeah and pressing
up should actually take you back to the
top with the stream in the navigation of
the web so basically you have to give to
activities at the top you have the
stream as well as a navigation drawer
but as soon as you jump into like cars
or something else you get taken to a new
activity with a sliding pane layout
which works on tablet and tablet as well
as own where the left side is your
master and the right side is your detail
so
I mean that's one way brochure but I
definitely you know frames with design
an action if you get a chance to take a
look at this we'll see if that pans out
it's just kind of a off-the-cuff idea
yeah I have to admit the that's the one
thing so I feel every single nature is
beautiful but the navigation is a little
weird and right now I'm just trying to
figure out how to get back to the
sarcastic yeah yeah it's definitely it's
a beautiful app and I think you know we
really want to emphasize the fact that
it looks great it even understanding
nothing in terms of Norwegian you're
still able to navigate it and understand
what's going on you've used icons in the
right places to be able to understand
like again here even without
understanding what these categories are
it's obvious to me that they are
categories and that i can use them to
navigate into the app and i can figure
out where searches I understand how to
change prices I understand what I'm
looking at what it represents and it
actually it represents a really good
example of what we should all be doing
when we create our apps which is try and
use it without being able to understand
any of the language even do a
localization in just gibberish so that
the text length through about the right
size but you have no idea what it says
and then give it to someone and see how
well they navigate it you know it gives
you a really good idea of how your
visual cues are working how the layout
other navigation how everything is
implying to them what they're looking at
without actually using the text as a cue
and for mobile app this is really
important because people don't
necessarily read what they're looking at
it's just kind of a truism for a lot of
things people don't read you can tell
them things a million times put it on
big screens explain something in detail
they're not going to read it they're
going to skip straight through it so you
need to make sure that the the rest of
the app pushes them in the right
direction gives them all the other cues
so that even if they're not paying
attention that is cleansing at the
screener they're making assumptions it
works out it does still do what they
expected to do and makes them feel
comfortable that they understand
how it works and how they can interact
with it and I think you've done a really
good job there it's just as we've said
repeatedly I think it's just a
navigation which could use a little bit
of a tweak and I think otherwise it's a
great effort it's a great looking at the
one thing that I really appreciate I
wanted to point out specifically because
it's very hard to do is that the app is
buttery smooth even though it has to
fetch quite a lot of data including
photos and you can see that the photos I
not only load in the background but they
also fade in with a nice effect ya mean
which makes the app field considerably
smoother and loss of rock so I think we
engineering behind the central ListView
really skeller I wanna graduate my last
two points of constructive criticism or
feedback first there's a distinct lack
of touch feedback throughout so you know
when you when you put your finger down
on something it should light up the
entire touch Aereo should light up to
indicate that you've got interacting
with it the second thing with us with
those photos they load in just
beautifully but as you're scrolling
through the list there's just white
space there and it almost feels like
they're just missing miss Alliant so you
may want to use a placeholder image
maybe even just that a slightly gray
like I like an off-white color to
indicate that this is a place other
space where something will load in
that'll don't want to potentially
improve you the feeling of alignment
yeah well it's good if you look into
these products they've actually done
that into the cases perera the-- that
already yeah when the photo is loading I
don't know not only yeah it's kind of
loading spinner but isn't yeah I like
the idea of a very slightly darker gray
box it is something so that you know
something is going to come back because
a really good idea everything i love how
buttery smooth everything is i like that
you've done that you can tell a lot of
thought has gone into how much pre
caching you do so when i do load up a
page for a new article i can swipe once
or like two or three photos and they're
there instantly but once i start to go
much further sort of then it's going to
do the reload so it doesn't aggressively
download all 9 photos but it will get
the first for the ones which i'm most
likely to look at those little touches
can make a really big difference so you
know nicely done the other thing i will
really a fan i hope you're ready I want
you to check it out and I don't know how
you feel but I feel like you know
swiping through photos obviously I want
to either look at one or the other and I
work to some apps where really do need
to swipe it all the way across is big
Finn your district he does this after
you've moved about maybe five or ten
millimeters it'll simply you know swipe
over to the next one so it just takes a
very tiny gesture to get it to move from
one photo to the other I really
appreciate that because it saves my
thumbs and my thumbs are up britax oh ok
I'm not quite seeing it happen that
quickly needs to go about halfway from I
as far as my eyes can see it ah it it's
definitely velocity sensitive and I
think that's probably appropriate yeah
so if you try it yeah it's a very small
throat will transfer yeah if you yeah
once once you get above a certain
velocity threshold and that's great it
just feels really good I think it's an
excellent gesture today I need two other
things which are Roman has has prompted
me on which are worth noting so one is
that a way you have the action bar icons
up here they don't have tool tips
associated so you want to make sure that
they do so if people long press on these
will tell them what it is that they're
trying to accomplish which is always
useful particularly for
people with visual impairments those
sorts of things make a really big
difference and while we're talking touch
targets it would be i think really
useful to allow users to select some of
the text in the description fields for
the items that they're looking at so you
do have a mechanism for sharing which
will allow you to send a link to that
particular item to someone great really
useful but I think it would also be
useful to be able to you know quickly
and easily select things like the price
or the description so that they can take
that cut it paste it put it into
something else maybe an email maybe a
document Google key whatever it is that
they're doing to try and keep track of
things so I think adding that
flexibility i think would be really
really useful by the way you know going
back to what we're talking about in some
of the other app so that what can you do
when you're not logged in right check
out that's a little heart button which
in my opinion be a star bit part of
whatever I now there's no explanatory
test text here and there probably should
be T but this is a good example of how
you can provide value without being
logged in get to a point in the app
where you have to be logged in in this
case to set a favorite and you're given
the opportunity to log in there at least
I think that's what's going on I believe
so i think the one comment i have here
is that it doesn't appear to be a way to
create an account if you don't already
have one is that because you can't no no
it's a-comin if you just we just haven't
going around to it yet it isn't
completely finished on outraged uh-huh
so the other thing and I know that given
that this is a retail store and I know
how this works and I'm sure that you
have your own database of people's
profiles which you which you're creating
on purpose if it doesn't have this
complicated back end it would be
interesting again to think of using
something like Google Plus to simplify
that login process so that I don't need
to go through and create an account I
hate creating accounts on my phone I
very seldom do it's usually a good
reason for me to decide not to use an
app if I have to go through this whole
process of doing something whereas with
Google+ it's much much easier it's just
a one click you know log in and then
accept so something to consider if you
don't have restrictions preventing you
from being able to take that approach
and this isn't just a plug for Google+
there there are other apps for instance
in America it's very common to have a
Twitter or Facebook account on the phone
any account provider that's that's
installed a an account provider plug-in
on the phone will offer your users a
OneTouch login so if you want to login
with twitter gonna log in with google
plus you want to offer multiple options
that's fine the most important thing is
that they can log in with just a couple
of touches because that will keep them
coming back to your app that well don't
prevent them from uninstalling your app
out of frustration because they don't
count so you'll see a greater attached
rated it's also a really great way of
maintaining users across devices so they
get a new phone or if they buy a new
tablet and are able to log in and get
all of the customizations that they did
for free without having to remember the
username and password that they created
two years ago it really helps just to
encourage people to a Z and said log
back in and keep using your app a lot of
people that run very popular services
don't think this is a very important
because they know that many of their
users have installed this app as they
love the service but if you look at the
way the trends are going that's not
going to last much longer there's been a
period of several years
our mobile update was driven by users
who had used the website and enjoyed it
and wanted the same thing on their
device but look at our statistics for
usage we're seeing many more people
interacting with the web and lift
services on their mobile phone to the
point where it's very likely that the
majority of your new users will come
from mobile experience in the future
step being able to offer them the quick
as possible path to useful behavior I
used functionality was going to be I
really important to your bottom line
yeah absolutely and it's all about
retention as well I mean I went through
the process last weekend while I was
shopping of trying to install and
registered my safeway app on my wife was
shopping and I was pushing the trolley
trying to get the safeway app installed
and I had to create an account and then
associate it with my safeway card and
the whole thing took like half an hour
which was fine because it's big shopping
but wasn't the best experience in terms
of encouraging me to actually use the
app a little and recommend it to anyone
else so you know it's about retention
it's about getting to a point where
you're driving a lot of new users from
mobile devices I think as Ian suggests
we're kind of heading to that direction
now where you can do be getting more and
more new users from mobile particularly
younger users who just just use their
phones for everything you know never
never had a desktop they'll use their
laptops so on yeah definitely definitely
an interesting area so cut up that moto
guzzi that's awesome yeah it's a lot of
nice things here anyway all right we
should we keep browsing out for hours
but that's probably not the most
effective use of anyone's time so thank
you very much for joining us all right
thanks for your time just guys thanks
thank you
all right now the next app that I have
probably got the wrong version installed
of on my sheet of paper is a real time T
bein so the developer of real time T I'm
guessing this barn not could be Bane
you'll have to tell me how to today oh
yeah a little less on run the auto tuner
for this one the water tuna are you
almost right hey Obama here bomber of
course hey my name is Cullen i'm the
creator of real-time Obama thank you for
joining up that's mostly useful for
people in oslo we use the tie bomber
which is the local metro subway service
the app provides a real-time view of the
table and network in oslo so it allows
you to see the network as it is long ah
once you're you know slow yeah oh I'm
getting there getting there yeah and so
you can you can see in real time
although maybe they didn't load I'm not
sure I I looked at it yesterday and I
saw all the little things moving around
I looked at it today and have not been
able to see any so I'm not entirely sure
what's going on oh maybe it's the wrong
version of the app seems like we know
there is any more motion of the earth
that's the very version but it looks
like maybe the day or hasn't loaded you
can try them back out of the Athenaeum I
was seeing you're seeing the mood with
the real all right I'll back out of this
and see if we can get to load up in
circles this is so cool so do you want
to tell us a little bit about it they
have better internet connectivity in New
York probably yeah this is like a dead
zone in this building no yeah so
remember rato is standing in what was
once i and ii rubens office and the
entire android program was built around
him said there is
kinds of wireless devices it's almost
like keynote at the moscone center
nothing works ya denya could you switch
to the other box there is a there is
well it's still a book maybe if you did
but the it starts at your GPS location
yes because well I did think about maybe
fixing that so if you're outside of Oslo
to always sit on a slave but I didn't
want to make too many assumptions on the
user's path so if you want to force to
load in Oslo you should switch off gps
right now it took I enjoy scrolling but
exactly something you want to consider
doing is you know you do have the gps
button effectively on the map anyway a
nice work on using the the latest
version of the Maps API you know being
able to sort of scroll and turn and
change the perspective on this stuff is
it was actually really fun see I don't
know why we can't get like any of the
locations that's interesting because
we're getting enough data to be able to
get the roots I don't know if you're
pulling the roots down server side or if
they are built into the app the roots
are built into the app so it's likely
that we're just not getting we're not
getting good updates just very strange
hmm I do you think it might it might
have been nicer to have a way to search
you know by station for instance that
would allow me to you know directly to
what I'm interested in no matter where I
am but it does also seem like you're
right that purely real time data on this
system it's unlikely to be useful
outside
so a couple of minor things while we
wait the first is I consider using like
a attends loosen action bar your entire
screen is the map go one step further
and make the action bar like translucent
above the map yeah there are some issues
of course with which showing the the
top-left compass and be my location
button but if you you don't need those
necessarily you may be okay with that
yeah looks so I'm curious to know if
there was a specific driver behind the
creation of the app you know is there a
reason that you put it together or is it
kind of an experimental hey we have this
real-time data wouldn't it be awesome it
was a bit of both I've done a lot of
Android development privately I was
private prediction I'd never really
bothered to put the mountains at the
Play Store because they were a bit messy
and work very well designed so it was
really an idea I had to force myself to
make enough that I would actually have
to think about the design and make it
usable yeah so it's really it sort of
just a play toy you could say it's a
pretty cool toy as toys going well I'm
coming out I had one winner comment
about the the line visibility so right
now you have a little eye icon pressing
that gives you a list of line may want
to make those checkboxes or something
like that where you can just show
multiple lines if you decide that it's
really like it's not useful to see lines
two and three you didn't want to see one
of them are all of them that's fine but
it is an option you wanted me you should
pop yeah I did think about it I'd tried
to make the the menu Kate use case the
simplest I would rather that I think
most people are going to look at one
line yes i would i would rather make up
the main use case but i did i did
investigate out there one thing that I
yes this is just a sort of Bell and
whistle thing but would be really cool
if each of these circles had some sort
of extra in you know an arrow or
something so you knew which direction it
was going now obviously I can sit here
and watch the circles move and I know
basically which direction they're going
but for instance of rain is broken down
I wouldn't know which trap it was on it
also realized in your humor II like your
short-term memory across a number of
different things on the screen to
recognize which way it's going so having
now is a great idea we could really help
fighter immediate at-a-glance view of
what's going on and maybe you had the
arrows only at a certain level like when
you zoom in to the point where you
actually can distinguish the different
blogs like when you're zoomed out you
see kind of all of them LOB's all on top
of each other narrows with even further
cluttered things when you're zoomed in
you mean yeah but yeah so it's a it's a
really nice app particularly when it uh
when you're actually seeing the the
movement of the of the trains i'm not
sure i'm really not sure why they're not
coming up here we do have internet
connectivity and it does seem to be
loading but it definitely doesn't seem
to be coming up such as you were really
missing y'all rate instead of asking
yeah I've got it on my other phone and
it looks great just it's not like we
will have connected to the Internet to
the to the overlay but I don't have a
lot of yet is uh well no actually I've
got to um first I there's a circle up at
the top of the screen has an eye in it
that appears to be basically just a data
provider um i would suggest that that's
probably less important than the share
icon so which is hidden in the overflow
menu I want to switch those round circle
I'm uh I'm not very good at bugging
people into sharing my yeah those shirts
to share oh it's to share the app well
done just help it since I've stubbing to
the place though I thought you're gonna
share like a loud or something
yeah we're to school to point and then
also you've got a when i click on a
particular car it looks like i should be
able to press this little pop-up that
comes up and in fact sometimes when i
press it it actually does change color
is if there were some activity
associated with it but there doesn't
seem to be an actually it's tough
finding color noun 1 yeah but it would
be cool to at that point you know when
you get into a detail screen for that
specific I guess vehicle come and then
from there maybe share share maybe sure
its projected route or something like
that something something more than just
kind of showing on screen but yeah I
think the utility of this app is
probably obvious to folks that are that
are using this transit for daddy that's
more a bug report or any than anything
and I'm like a future requests to I
think if I were using this app I would
also want to click on the station and
see when the next train is arriving you
have that information if I click on the
train but if I'm at a particular station
and I might be more interested in when
I'll see the next train at that point
also I was a bit worried about
cluttering them up with too much
information so I wasn't really sure of a
clever way to do that because obviously
once the trains around them up which
then on the moment it's quite a lot of
data on screen at one time yeah but
you're always going the the station it's
part of the Google Maps there's a little
tea in a circle yeah so and in fact if I
were in the Google Maps application and
clicked on this key that's exactly what
I would see is the the trains I that
were available at that station I don't
think I'd see the real time data that's
the value that you provide yeah
the other thing which might be useful as
well as to provide some kind of link
into to google maps so that once you're
looking at something here so again if
you're a if you're a local resident of
oslo and you know where the stations are
and you know how to get there and
everything else and you are really just
looking to to get an update as to
basically how long you need to wait for
your for your next train to arrive then
you know then it's fine but it may be
worth considering you know visitors
people who are new to the city who might
want to download the app and be able to
find out how to get to that particular
station from wherever they are so rather
than building all of that into your mat
which i think is fair to say would be
overkill would be able to have a way of
being able to you know as i say when you
press on a station be able to say you
know get directions to here which then
keeps you out into google maps to
actually you know show you how to get
there yeah yeah it's a it's a nice app
it's it's really well-designed really
clean really uncluttered yeah i think
it's think it's a really good effort
here till your the location in maths guy
there isn't a way to install a like a
layer provider and mouse app is there no
really cool though innit yeah i think we
used to love my maps then you can open
up a ml file and we will earth exactly
but that that's nothing like this yeah
yeah cool alright alright yeah thank you
very much thank you alright so i think
that's all we've got time for i'd like
to thank hands for organizing GDG app
clinic oslo so a round of applause for
everyone for your for your organizer
so what thank you very much thank you
all right thanks guys